I want you to give a warm welcome to DJ
Phantom
I'm really proud of you right great
seventh cervical thank you me
they smoke these house my dream
come on
come on Logan
mom no you can't I was in the middle of
a Missy
he's knocking asking for too much I did
knock and so did your father
good luck hearing anything over that I'm
gonna stop wasting your time with all
this @ej stuff just so you know this DJ
stuff could make me a lot of money if
that's what you're worried about
just like my Tupperware parties can make
$15,000 a night Oh
Stanford does not offer a major in DJing
is there a reason you're up here you
just here to crush all my hopes and
dreams honey your father wants to know
if you were anywhere near his car
no was Blake Logan stay away from the
Porsche or your father will kill you I
mean he's funny about his car I'd like
you to keep your room cleaner yeah and
you know I'm noticing these nudie photos
is Blake putting those up yeah mom it's
all bike I used to look like that